lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
explorar si al evaluar una expresión con
paréntesis afecta el resultado si le
evaluó con paréntesis o sin paréntesis
por ejemplo tengo esta expresión que
está aquí y la voy a evaluar utilizando
los paréntesis y sin ellos primero vamos
a hacerlo con paréntesis y recuerda lo
que hemos trabajado sobre el orden de
las operaciones esto nos dice que cuando
hay paréntesis es lo primero que hay que
hacer las demás operaciones
multiplicación división suma y resta se
realizan primero las multiplicaciones y
divisiones y después la suma y la resta
lo primero que tengo que hacer es esto
que está dentro del paréntesis que es 8
menos 3 y 8 menos 3 es 5
y ahora mi expresión sería equivalente a
tener 5 x 8
-3 muy bien 5 por 840
- 340 menos 3 es igual a 37 y ya terminé
de evaluar esta primera expresión
ahora hagámoslo sin paréntesis voy a
reescribir esta expresión sin paréntesis
o sea que me quedaría ocho menos tres
por 8 menos
si recuerdas el orden de las operaciones
lo primero que voy a tener que hacer es
la multiplicación que sería equivalente
a pensar como si tuviéramos unos
paréntesis aquí y los voy a poner para
hacer énfasis en que primero es la
multiplicación entonces 3 por 8 es 24
yo ahora voy a reescribir los otros dos
términos que están en la expresión
entonces va a ser 8 menos 24 menos 3
muy bien 8 - 24 es menos 16 sí estamos
obteniendo un número negativo y menos 16
menos 3 nos da como resultado menos 10 y
y podemos observar que el resultado de
las dos operaciones es totalmente
diferente